many crypto enthusiasts rejoiced when
the Securities and Exchange Commission
gave companies a green light to sell
exchang traded funds in the US that
directly hold Bitcoin in just a few days
of trading it became pretty clear who
the big winners were I'm going to tell
you who's winning so far why they're
winning and what this could mean for the
future of crypto investment let's get
into it Black Rock which boast more than
$1 trillion of assets under management
was the big winner on the first few days
of trading black Rock's ey shares
Bitcoin trust ETF known by the ticker
ibit brought in almost $500 million and
had more than $1.6 billion of trading
volume in the first two days according
to Bloomberg data Fidelity's Bitcoin ETF
had about $400 million in inflows and
did about $1.1 billion in volume the
fund from Kathy Woods Arc Investment
Management had around $111 million of
inflows and just under $450 million of
trading volume other funds brought in
just a fraction of black Rock's Hall
ETFs from companies like Valkyrie and
Wisdom Tree each saw around $1 million
of volume in their first two days of
trading as my colleague Jack pitcher
reported analysts predict that the firm
that draws the most funds early will
have an advantage to become the go-to
Bitcoin ETF for institutional investors
since there were nearly a dozen ETFs
made available to the public the day
after the sec's decision no company
could get an advantage by being first so
asset managers almost universally cut
their fees Black Rock originally planned
a management fee of. 3% for its ETF but
after it was real that other managers
were charging lower fees they cut their
fee to
0.25% and they lowered it to 0.12% for
the first year or until the fund holds
more than $5 billion in addition to the
lower fee black Rock's ibit holds around
$500 million worth of bitcoin that's
more Bitcoin than any other spot ETF
with the exception of the grayscale
Bitcoin trust ETF investors favor funds
that hold more assets because it makes
it easier to buy and sell the fund
that's especially important with assets
like crypto that can have big swings in
price grayscales ETF actually holds 50
times more Bitcoin than black rocks and
has seen more than double the trading
volume but over the first two days of
trading those flows were all negative
and investors pulled almost $600 million
out according to Bloomberg's data one
big factor grayscales ETF charges a fee
that's six times higher than black rocks
and most other spot bit coin ETFs the
numbers so far suggest that investors
dislike fees more than they like large
asset
Holdings so what does this mean for the
future of crypto investing having Black
Rock as the primary Bitcoin ETF could
make a big difference first it could
mean a lot more Bitcoin buying ETF asset
managers need to buy and hold sufficient
quantities of the underlying asset so as
more people buy their Bitcoin ETF Black
Rock will buy more Bitcoin and with1
trillion do of assets under management
Black Rock has a lot of buying power
Black Rock and others have already
started making a pitch to more
traditional investors about why they
should get into crypto Bringing In
traditional institutional investors who
manage millions or even billions of
dollars is a big part of why the fees
are solow to be profitable with fees
below 3% funds will need to bring in a
lot of money into the tens of billions
of dollars says Eric bouches the senior
ETF analyst for Bloomberg's research arm
the most popular Bitcoin ETF also stands
to bring in a new group of investors who
haven't had a lot of exposure to
traditional investing that could be very
profitable as those investors get older
and invest more money in the future
Bitcoin ETFs could also create a
dividing line between providers Vanguard
like black rock is known for its lowcost
investment vehicles but Vanguard has
said it won't offer access to the
Bitcoin ETF on its platform the big
picture is that based on the early days
of trading black rock is looking well
positioned to win a lot of benefits from
the newly approved Bitcoin ETF That
Could set them up to dominate Bitcoin
and new digital assets that are approved
by the SEC for years to
come